[Musique]
on ne se connaît pas mais je sais que
nous avons un point en commun
nous adorons les nouvelles technologies
[Musique]
et nous sommes connectés en permanence
twitter google et apple ont changé nos
vies
le patron de facebook mark zuckerberg
parle d'égal à égal avec obama je
m'appelle barack obama et je suis celui
qui a réussi à convaincre marc de mettre
une cravate et une veste
[Applaudissements]
les chefs d'état du monde entier
viennent en pèlerinage dans la silicon
valley c'est ici en californie à san
francisco que s'invente le monde de
demain celui du 21e siècle c'est ici
qu'une révolution s'est initié à travers
les nouvelles technologies
derrière cette révolution technologique
se cache une autre révolution plus
politique
les ingénieurs de la silicon valley ne
fabrique pas que des machines
il rêve de reprogrammer notre système il
existe de meilleures formes de
gouvernement que ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui mieux que la démocratie en
utilisant les nouvelles technologies un
meilleur des mondes avec moins d'impôts
moins de services publics - de
frontières et moins de gouvernement
[Musique]
ben
mon enquête commence à san francisco
depuis toujours c'est une ville à part
aux états unis lieu de naissance du
mouvement hippie dans les années 60
c'est la ville de toutes les libertés du
mouvement gay et de la contre-culture
elle est aussi le berceau des nouvelles
technologies
tokyo
je m'installe dans une petite maison à
quelques kilomètres du centre-ville
obtenir une autorisation de tournage
j'appelle le service de presse de google
ça commence mal
je tombe sur une messagerie vous êtes
sur le répondeur de google laisser un
message
oui je vous appelle pour savoir si vous
pouvez répondre à ma demande d'interview
d'un attaché de presse de google
merci vous êtes sur le répondeur d'apple
laissé un message aux gens maggie désolé
de vous déranger à nouveau c'est hugo le
journaliste français de la télévision de
canal plus
vous êtes sur le répondeur de twitter
laissez un message twitter facebook
apple personne ne me rappellera jamais
[Musique]
je décide d'aller tenter ma chance sur
place
mountainview à 40 km de san francisco
le siège social de google s'étend sur 40
kilomètres carrés
les salariés circule en vélo d'un
bâtiment à l'autre
[Musique]
cinquante mille employés dans le monde
dont 1200 qui sont millionnaires
[Musique]
google est aujourd'hui la marque la
mieux cotée au monde
chaque jour des centaines de touristes
se font photographier devant la porte
principale et les cookies géant en
plâtre cette famille est arrivée ce
matin de caroline du nord
monfils a 12 ans et tous ses copains lui
ont dit oh mon dieu si tu vas à san
francisco tu dois aller voir le campus
de google
alors tu te sens comment ici cet
excitant d'être ici parce que google
c'est mon navigateur sur internet depuis
longtemps et y est trop vrai c'est cool
c'est mieux que disneyland
[Musique]
oui monsieur on peut faire un tour dans
les bureaux non non vous devez être avec
quelqu'un je travaillais ici je vous
paye pour faire un tour sans badge on ne
peut pas entrer
non vous ne pouvez pas vous qu'on est
tout seul la sécurité va vous attraper
il ya une sécurité google
oui donc on peut circuler librement d'or
mais par l'intérieur oui mais même si
vous restez dehors il faut être prudent
la sécurité de google peut vous jeter à
tout moment par exemple si vous voit
vous promener et que vous dites que vous
n'êtes pas accompagnés ils vont vous
demander de partir d'accord et si on est
journaliste
alors dans ces cas là ça se passe
comment vous êtes journaliste
une mauvaise idée
vous allez devoir partir et je ne peux
pas vous emmener à l'intérieur c'est sûr
en effet des patrouilles ou google font
des rondes au bout de dix minutes
un vigile à vélo nous repèrent et nous
interpelle alors nous enregistrons
discrètement vous filmer des employés
pourquoi
l'approché personne ne parlait à
personne et surtout pas aux employés si
l'on vous êtes viré ok on a l'impression
d'être une grande menace c'est notre
protocole ici à google son quelqu'un va
vous surveiller en permanence
oui la sécurité qui va nous surveiller
partout les caméras des caméras et des
personnes
nous rentrons à san francisco et en
chemin nous recevons un email de google
qui nous dit qu'ils ne
qui n'ont pas de porte parole disponible
pour le moment donc il ne communique pas
c'est patrick surprise
la seule entreprise de la silicon valley
qui nous a ouvert ses portes
c'est airbnb le numéro un mondial de la
location d'appartements sur internet
bonjour nous avons rendez vous signez
ici je vous en prie airbnb où la vie
rêvée dans une start up californienne
on va on va monter à la salle à manger
lisa dubost une franco danoise de la
direction des ressources humaines nous
fait le tour du propriétaire
bienvenue dans le temple du cool si
c'est une autre salle de réunion salle
de démo en fait mais qu'on utilise pour
le yoga trois fois par semaine donc vous
pouvez le voir on a des tapis de yoga
ici donc ici c'est un environnement que
nos ingénieurs que certains de nos
ingénieurs ont créé eux mêmes il ya une
boule à facettes et les guitares
approché au mur il n'y a pas trop de
lumière du jour moi c'est pas une salle
dans laquelle je vous envie de
travailler mais et se sentent bien et il
ya ya toute une culture autour de
l'année en cours ça c'est du leaser
printing ils ont imprimé les yeux de dan
acquis à nos ingénieurs sur tous ces du
lycée du ces de l'impression c'est
l'impression laser je crois qu'il
faudrait le soir fait vous montrer le
petit déjeuner
et tout est fait maison tout est fait
ici sur place donc par nos chefs ici
dans la cuisine on travaille avec des
prestataires locaux des fournisseurs
locaux des fermiers locaux pour tout ce
qui est fruits légumes viandes poissons
c'est bio absolument faille chaque jour
l'entreprise fournit les trois repas
gratuitement à ses 600 employés
plus besoin de rentrer chez soi donc en
effet j'ai tendance à en tout cas
prendre un petit déjeuner déjeuner et la
plupart de médine est ici plutôt que de
sortir dîner en ville
étant donné que je suis ici c'est bon je
rentrais disons que dans mon frigo ya
pas grand chose du champagne français
bien sûr les salariés vivent en vase
clos travail parfois sept jours sur sept
mais pour lisa aucun problème comme pas
les armes et si je pense que si on
pointait ce serait pas au bénéfice de 2
de l'entreprise n'at on pas nos arts ici
c'est tous ensemble mais chacun pour soi
il y avait 110 cas ici qu'on nous trouve
un an
enfin c'est je pense que c'est différent
les syndicats scellé comment s'appelle
un des cas c'est la responsable de
communication qui prend le volant
en france tu sais il ya des gens qui
s'occupent des employés par exemple
s'ils sont un problème personnel dans la
rue non par exemple s'ils sont virés et
qu'il pense que la raison n'est pas
valable
ici on parle directement aux avocats non
oui ici on n'a pas ça pourtant ça a
l'air cool ici les salariés n'ont pas de
syndicats mais ils ont de bons salaires
chez un bienne be on commence à 7000 $
par mois chez facebook à 9000
narry tech a fait la fortune de san
francisco la ville compte aujourd'hui 11
milliardaire mais ce que ne dit jamais
les géants du net c'est que la pauvreté
aussi s'est accrue dans la région 20 %
de la population vit avec moins d'un
dollar par jour le nombre de sdf a
augmenté de 25% en deux ans l'économie
virtuelle créé très peu d'emplois et
avec l'inflation des salaires
le prix de l'immobilier a explosé en
moins d'un an certains loyers ont doublé
8500 euros pour un trois pièces résultat
les plus pauvres n'arrive plus à se
loger et se font expulser sur cette
carte de la ville chaque point rouge
représente une famille expulsée pour la
seule année 2013
les chiffres ont augmenté de 25%
voilà mon immeuble je vis au dernier
étage johnny par exemple vit en dessous
claudel son enfant juste en bas
l'expulsion c'est aussi ce qui menace
evans il est professeur de sciences et
gagne correctement sa vie mais sa maison
dans le quartier populaire de michonne
vient d'être rachetée à titre personnel
par un avocat de google
le nouveau propriétaire s'est servi d'un
petit acte de loi sur le logement
il permet à ceux qui acquiert un bien
locatif et qui déclare en suisse ne peut
s'en vouloir louer d'appartements
d'expulser rapidement les habitants gogo
c'est pourtant dans la charte éthique de
google ils disent qu'ils veulent être de
bons voisins ça y avoir un comportement
responsable
là où ils vivent et là où ils
travaillent c'est la plupart des autres
industries ne disent pas ça ils le
disent
donc d'un côté il me donne de l'espoir
mais de l'autre puisqu'il ne le font pas
ça me déçoit encore plus la maison fait
trois étages les sept familles qui
habitent sont en instance d'expulsion
à moins qu'il soit vraiment riche les
gens ne peuvent plus payer les loyers
ici donc un professeur que moi un
chauffeur de taxi un artiste un pompier
un employé de café tous ceux qui ont un
métier qui ne les rend pas riche mais
qui aident à rendre cette vie meilleure
eh bien tous ces gens vont devoir partir
c'est dimanche une chance peut-être
pourparlers avec le nouveau propriétaire
[Musique]
en attendant que tout le monde s'en
aille
il habite un appartement du deuxième
étage personne ne répond
ce cadre de google a installé une caméra
de surveillance dans le couloir pour
préserver sa tranquillité
[Musique]
tout le quartier populaire de michonne
est en train de se transformer à toute
vitesse en zone résidentielle pour
millionnaires du net
au bout de la rue voici la maison encore
en travaux de mark zuckerberg le jeune
patron de facebook vient d'acheter cette
demeure pour 10 millions de dollars
[Musique]
à deux pas de là une agence immobilière
commercialise ce nouvel immeuble design
voici donc l'immeuble il s'appelle vida
nous avons cent quatorze nouveaux
appartements et il fait huit étages il
est constitué d'acier de béton et le
chantier sera finie dans trois mois dans
son bureau en miniature wendy novia la
responsable a recréé l'endroit dont
elles rêvent les sdf sont remplacés par
des cabriolets bien garé dans une rue
bien propre ici wendy vise une clientèle
précise l'élite de l'high tech
elle a déjà vendu la moitié des biens
voilà la cuisine ici il y à une prise
vous pouvez ranger votre smartphone
votre portable
car à san francisco beaucoup de gens
travaillent dans le domaine des
nouvelles technologies
et même quand ils sont chez eux ils
travaillent beaucoup donc ils utilisent
ça comme un comptoir et puis le soir ils
rangent l'ordinateur en dessous donc
c'est vraiment pensé pour les employés
des nouvelles technologies absolument
vous savez près de 90 % de nos clients
viennent de cette industrie nous avons
des gens de facebook google twitter
hubert pour ce petit deux pièces
il faut compter sept cent mille euros au
minimum au dernier étage le penthouse
souvent un million huit des tarifs qui
exclut évidemment les habitants du
quartier est-ce que les gens du quartier
peuvent se payer un tel appartement
c'est cher ici pour eux non oui c'est
vrai donc ils doivent trouver un boulot
avec un meilleur salaire pour pouvoir se
payer ça la plupart des gens du quartier
ne peuvent pas se le permettre
[Musique]
régulièrement les habitants manifestent
devant cet immeuble qui est devenue le
symbole de la colonisation du quartier
par l'argent
[Musique]
mon histoire est très banal ici à mi
chemin mais ces compagnies ne veulent
pas l'entendre
ça ne les intéresse vraiment pas du tout
moi je suis inquiète pour mes petits
frères
de quoi va hériter la prochaine
génération ils vont devoir vivre avec
des gens qui ne se mélangent pas du tout
avec eux qui les regardent de haut et
c'est vraiment terrible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les géants du net n'ont jamais voulu
répondre aux mises en cause des
habitants mais nous avons trouvé un
homme qui représente facebook twitter
airbnb et qui est prêt à parler c'est un
lobbyiste alex türk
il minimise l'impact négatif des
nouveaux riches sur la ville on ne peut
pas plaire à tout le monde ici à san
francisco comme dans n'importe quelle
autre ville
c'est vrai que c'est cher de vivre ici
qu'il y à beaucoup d'inégalités
mais ça existait déjà avant l'arrivée
des géants du net
oui mais ses compagnons ont fait
exploser les prix du marché
ils ont leur part de responsabilité mais
ça a toujours été une ville chère qui
attire des gens du monde entier
certaines compagnies du net sont accusés
de ne pas redistribuer les richesses
il faudrait que ça s'améliore non oui
c'est vrai et il essaye chaque jour de
mieux faire mais vous savez ça fait des
années que je travaille au quotidien
avec ces gens et ils sont concentrés sur
leur travail leurs produits sur leur
envie d'aller loin
elle ce n'est pas qu'ils s'en foutent ou
qu'il n'ait pas envie d'aider mais ils
sont tellement occupés
ce sont des entrepreneurs qui
travaillent 24 heures sur 24
les nouveaux oligarques du net ne se
contente pas de privatiser des quartiers
de san francisco il privatise aussi les
services publics de la ville
[Musique]
regardez bien ces bus qui sillonnent san
francisco ils ramassent leurs passagers
aux arrêts municipaux à première vue des
transports en commun comme les autres
mais en fait ils appartiennent à google
facebook ou apple
seuls les cadres de la silicon valley
ont le droit de monter dans ces navettes
privé à l'intérieur sièges en cuir et
wifi gratuit métro boulot dodo version 4
étoiles ces bus sont devenues un sujet
tabou à san francisco pour avoir des
éléments d'information nous tournerons à
distance tu m'entends
bonjour vous attendez le google bus oui
je suis journaliste français je peux
vous poser des questions sur ces bus
désolé je ne peux vous donner aucune
information
pardon je ne peux vous donner aucune
information comme je voulais d'y envoyer
un mail à presse à google.com m vous
avez des ordres pour ne pas parler vous
avez des questions envoyées au service
presse
mais là je vous pose une question et je
ne vous répond pas d'accord vous me
dites d'envoyer un email c'est ça pour
tenter d'en savoir plus
je change de trottoir je me glisse dans
une file d'attenté d'un bus apple
[Musique]
les tensions qu'il ya eu c'est à cause
des bus privés c'est ça oui il faudrait
que cela reste vivable pour les gens du
coin ou ne veulent pas perdre l'âme du
quartier mais c'est compliqué au bout de
quelques minutes
l'employé s'aperçoit qu'elle est filmée
elle panique ce gars qui filme au coin
de la rue il est avec vous ne vous
inquiétez pas j'ai besoin de mon boulot
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît ne
montrez pas mon visage si le sujet est
sensible
c'est que ces bus privés font polémique
à san francisco aujourd'hui les bus
publics avec la bande rouge sont obligés
d'attendre en double file beaucoup
d'habitants dénonce l'utilisation
d'infrastructures municipales au seul
bénéfice des employés de la silicon
valley il y a quelques mois des
riverains en colère ont pris d'assaut
les navettes privé on a notre carte de
transports publics pour monter dans le
bus
descendez d'ici c'est un bus privé
dégagé c'est un bus privé c'est un bus
privé
dégagé je dis que c'est un bus privé
sortez du bus
d'autres bloquent les navettes déguisé
aux couleurs de google
[Musique]
le pire c'est que le stationnement de
ces navettes privés sur des arrêts
public est illégale et passible d'une
contravention de 271 dollars selon ces
manifestants les géants du net ont une
dette d'un milliard de dollars de
contraventions envers la collectivité
une dette que la ville n'a jamais
réclamé pour tenter d'apaiser les
esprits
google a mis au point une liste
d'arguments des éléments de langage à
l'usagé des salariés donc dans ce
document interne de google
on leur propose par exemple de dire mon
bus permet à mes collègues et moi de
moins polluer en laissant notre voiture
au garage où je suis très fier de vivre
à san francisco et de faire partie de la
communauté ou encore je prends le bus
j'habite à san francisco et je fais du
volontariat
aujourd'hui situation impensable il ya
quelques années google n'est plus très
bien vu à san francisco dans certains
bars les signes ostentatoires de
technologies ne sont plus autorisés
sahin slocum on a fait l'amère
expérience
cette consultante en nouvelles
technologies ne quitte jamais ses google
grâce je peux vous envoyer un e-mail
tout de suite
bonjour hugo bonne journée à san mateo
et là je vous filme en train de me
filmer l'année dernière sarah entre dans
un bar avec ses lunettes google les
clients là prennent directement à partie
elle se met à filmer situe la ville ne
me touchez pas je vous fais un procès
[Musique]
je filme 1
allez casse toi je pense qu'il montrait
pour une cadre de google très riche il y
a beaucoup de colère et de ressentiment
c'est vu comme un symbole de cette élite
de l'ateq donc depuis mon agression j'ai
toujours mon taser électrique avec moi
ça fait peur aux gens ça peut les
paralyser et les choquer sarah a été la
première victime public des nouvelles
technologies depuis d'autres agressions
ont eu lieu dans la silicon valley les
géants du net ne se contente pas de
privatiser les transports publics
certains voient plus loin ils ont
commencé à privatiser la police
bienvenue à menlo park à une trentaine
de kilomètres de san francisco une
petite ville de 29 mille habitants où se
trouve le quartier général de facebook
à deux pas le géant des réseaux sociaux
à financer un commissariat de quatre
personnes trois cent mille dollars pour
le bail et la décoration
le commissaire bertini porte parole de
la police locale nous fait la visite
comme vous pouvez le voir notre
commissariat et décoré dans le pur style
de facebook par exemple une de leur
marque de fabrique c'est que rien n'est
figé car ils s'agrandissent tout le
temps voilà c'est vraiment leur style et
où est le quartier général de facebook
le quartier général est un pâté de
maisons d'ici mais ils construisent en
ce moment un nouveau campus et il est
juste derrière nous ici et vous pouvez
nous le montrer il faut sortir et si
vous regardez juste là au coin c'est le
nouveau siège qui est en construction le
terrain de facebook commence derrière
cette barrière dans quelques mois de
nouveaux bâtiments vont pousser sur ce
terrain vague
donc c'est aussi pour ça que facebook
voulait que le poste de police soit ici
exactement
et l'autre chose mais donc ce n'est pas
seulement pour être un bon voisin c'est
aussi pour leurs propres intérêts oui
tout à fait disons que c'est une
situation gagnant gagnant c'est sûr
la police est-elle devenue l'agent de
sécurité de facebook vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'avoir été achetée par
facebook
on m'a déjà demandé si facebook reçoit
un traitement de faveur mais s'il n'y a
aucun quiproquo nous n'avons jamais
proposé ça et ils ne l'ont jamais
demandé ils font ça juste pour être de
bons voisins de bons voisins qui ne se
sont pas contentés de rénover les locaux
de la police
nous nous sommes procuré le contrat de
travail de la chef de poste
l'officier marie ferguson et là surprise
il est précisé que le salaire de
l'officier sera payé par facebook
deux cent mille dollars par an facebook
est généreux c'est le double du salaire
habituel d'un policier
marie ferguson et le premier officier de
police aux états unis dont le salaire
n'est pas payée par les finances
publiques mais par une compagnie privée
officiellement elle est une policière
comme les autres mais son employeur lui
a quand même demandé un petit extra la
seule chose que facebook a demandé pour
mon poste c'est de créer un plan
d'évacuation pour les employés en cas de
violences c'est un nouveau plan oui
c'est un nouveau plan car ces faits sur
mesure juste pour ce campus
vous savez il est très grand et vous le
faites pour d'autres sociétés et
d'autres sociétés le veulent on le fera
certaines ont exprimé un intérêt donc on
va le mettre en place et vous commencez
avec facebook n'est ce pas car il faut
bien commencer quelque part
les millions de dollars des géants du
net arrange bien les pouvoirs publics
dont les finances sont à sec les caisses
de la ville sont vides et ça ne va pas
s'arranger
car à san francisco certaines
multinationales de la silicon valley ne
veulent plus payer d'impôts locaux
c'est le cas de twitter en 2011 la firme
a menacé de quitter san francisco si
elle n'obtenait pas d'exemption d'impôts
locaux pour tous ses nouveaux employés
pour les six années à venir une perte
pour la ville estimés à plus de 50
millions de dollars
[Applaudissements]
les syndicats de service public sont en
colère ils estiment que la collectivité
et les et je vous présente larry
bradshaw il est ambulancier à san
francisco bonjour merci à tous d'être là
vous savez ça fait 20 ans que je
travaille pour la ville et quelque chose
de bizarre se passe ici on a
l'impression que - vous gagnez d'argent
plus la mairie vous dis c'est trop
en revanche si vous vous appelez twitter
si votre prix est estimé à 36 milliards
de dollars que vous avez levé deux
milliard de dollars à la bourse l'année
dernière alors la mairie change de ton
et vous dit combien peut-on vous donner
en plus
est-ce que cela vous va vous êtes
d'accord la mairie ne communique pas sur
les montants de ces exemptions de
charges entre amis elle ne veut pas que
le public sache
mais en creusant de notre côté nous
savons que pour cette seule année
twitter économie 56 millions de dollars
d'impôts locaux qu'elle ne reverse pas à
la ville selon les syndicats ce cadeau
fiscal twitter a des effets très concret
sur la vie de tous les jours des
habitants de san francisco au
département de la santé publique il y à
120 postes d'infirmières vacants 120
postes
ils sont supposés être payés par la
ville mais qu'elle ne peut pas payer par
manque d'argent
donc on donne des milllions à des
sociétés de technologie
pendant que ces postes d'infirmières
eux restent vives pourquoi la mairie de
san francisco at elle cédé à la pression
de twitter et bly le maire de la ville
n'a pas souhaité nous répondre
c'est son conseiller économique qui nous
reçoit vous croyez vraiment qu'une
société qui amasse des milliards de
dollars doit s'abstenir de payer des
impôts locaux
la question plus pertinente c'est de
savoir si ça valait le coup au vu de la
revitalisation économique que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
avant twitter était affecté par les
impôts qu'il devait reverser à la ville
aujourd'hui tout cela est modifié mais à
l'époque ils nous ont fait comprendre
qu'ils allaient quitter san francisco à
cause de son système de taxe trop
positifs mais ces compagnies sont très
riche et ce qu'elle ne pourrait pas
donner un peu plus pour la ville elles
font déjà des choses pourrait-elle faire
plus bien sûr et nous le voudrions mais
au final c'est à chaque compagnie de
décider ce qu'elle veut faire et nous
essayons de leur faciliter la tâche
il avait bougé dans une autre ville nous
aurions de toute façon pas profité de
l'argent qu'il génère dans le quartier
où ils sont installés par exemple des
petits commerces qu'ils font vivre en
allant déjeuner dans le quartier ou
prendre un café ou les entreprises de
services avec qui il travaille
la présence du géant at elle un impact
dans le quartier pas tant que ça les
salariés de twitter vivent en quasi
autarcie dans une forteresse
[Musique]
à l'intérieur un restaurant
gastronomique entièrement gratuit pour
les salariés pour se détendre un jardin
arboré sur la terrasse pour poser mes
questions à twitter j'ai tout essayé les
traditionnels email aux attachés de
presse
sans succès les coups de fil vous êtes
sur les répondeurs de twitter laisser un
message
[Musique]
finalement je me suis rendu à leur siège
est-ce qu'on pourrait parler avec
quelqu'un de la communication twitter
vous savez qu'il faut envoyer un mail on
en a envoyé plein ils savent qu'on veut
une interview mais ne répondent pas vous
pouvez leur dire que la télévision
française à la suite
vous connaissez et vont nous rappeler au
final j'ai twitté twitter bonjour
twitter avez vous respectez vos
engagements auprès de la ville et
pourquoi ne payez-vous pas d'impôts
locaux et j'attends toujours leur
réponse
en tous les cas twitter a ouvert la voie
désormais à san francisco une dizaine
d'autres compagnies de l'high tech ne
payent plus d'impôts locaux les impôts
c'est la hantise des géants du net
la plupart des multinationales pratiquer
l'évasion fiscale à grande échelle ce
qu'elle appelle de l'optimisation
fiscale des mécanismes tout à fait
légaux qui permettent d'échapper à
l'impôt le champion toutes catégories
c'est apple en 2011
un rapport du sénat américain a épinglé
officiellement une filiale du géant à la
pomme aui pour apple opérations
internationales ils sont installées en
irlande
donc ici il est écrit que apple
opérations internationales ont engrangé
30 milliards de bénéfices en cinq ans et
que sur ces 30 milliards de bénéfices
ils ne paient aucun impôt
30 milliards de dollars nets d'impôts un
petit tour de magie qui ne doit rien au
hasard
démonstration ah oui est une filiale
d'apple basé à cork en irlande
ses revenus proviennent de différentes
activités très lucratives en asie en
inde ou au moyen-orient
du côté des impôts américain ah oui
n'est pas taxables car le fisc américain
ne peut taxer que les sociétés dont le
siège réside aux états unis mais
halloween est pas taxables non plus en
irlande
car ces réunions stratégiques ont tout
lu aux états unis dans la silicon valley
et pour le fisc irlandais ce qui compte
c'est l'endroit où sont prises les
décisions les plus importantes du point
de vue fiscal
ah oui et donc un fantôme il n'existe
nulle part
ce fantôme fiscale a tout de même un
visage
cathy kearney la directrice et unique
employé d'hawaii une irlandaise de 50
ans j'ai contacté apple pour
l'interviewer malheureusement katyn ne
sera pas disponible pour une interview
le service de presse a refusé en fait ce
qui est rigolo c'est que on en demande
de les interviewer ils nous répondent
par la négative tout de suite mais après
nous pose plein de questions sur ce
qu'on veut faire sur le titre de
l'émission sur la durée sur la date de
diffusion sur l'angle exacte du sujet
donc en réalité moi qui demande une
interview c'est moi qui ai 2 qui devient
interviewé quoi pour tenté d'interviewer
cathy qui en est je me rends en irlande
ce petit pays à l'un des taux
d'imposition les plus bas d'europe
pour en profiter plusieurs géants du net
y ont installé leur siège européen
facebook google et bien sûr apple dont
le siège est basé dans la petite ville
de cork
je me suis procuré le registre du
commerce de la ville en irlande cathy
kearney est bien la seule employée
d'hawaii la filiale aux 30 milliards de
dollars de revenus l'adresse daoui se
trouve au siège d'apple
je me rends sur le parking je croise des
employés des autres filiales d'apple
personne ne semble connaître cathy
corner
la femme qui valait 30 pillards vous
connaissez cathy cornet s'est elle non
je suis désolé mais elle est la patronne
apple opérations internationales adacore
vous connaissez cathy corner vous savez
qui c'est mais vous êtes dit je suis
journaliste je cherche la directrice de
apple opérations internationales vous la
connaissez
avec son unique employé irlandaise ah
oui est une coquille vide qui permettent
à apple de ne pas payer d'impôts pour
que cela soit légal il leur fallait une
employée de nationalité irlandaise katic
urnes est une ancienne comptable faisait
la faire nous interrogeons madame la
maire de cork sur la présence de la
filiale d'apple dans sa ville est-ce que
c'est elle katy kearney oui oui je pense
bien oui je sais qu'elle a un trait au
poste chez apple mais vous savez ce
qu'elle fait concrètement elle est
présidente j'imagine
elle s'occupe d'une filiale d'apple qui
a fait un profit de 30 milliards de
dollars en quatre ans mais qui n'a pas
d'employés c'est fantastique quelqu'un
qui a ce genre de capacité on sait que
c'est possible ça doit être une femme
très intelligente
je la connais pas bien j'étais pas au
courant mais elle doit être une grande
entrepreneuse ah oui très grande ou et
oui très grande nous ne pouvons pas être
responsables des sociétés qui sont
contrôlés dirigé en dehors de notre pays
mais elle devrait payer des impôts non
oui je suppose mais vous savez le
gouvernement est heureux comme ça tout
comme les impôts ces compagnies n'ont
pas de privilèges spéciaux ici et nous
sommes prêts à accueillir toute
institution internationale qui
voudraient le vérifier regling lors ce
que je sais c'est que nous ne violons
aucune règle aucune langue
en irlande tout le monde s'y retrouve
mais aux états unis les pratiques
fiscales d'apple commence à faire
grincer des dents en 2013
le sénat a convoqué tim cook le pdg
d'apple devant une commission denquête
pour lui demander des comptes sur ses
filiales irlandaises jurait de dire la
vérité et rien que la vérité
je le jure nous sommes fiers d'être une
société américaine est également fiers
de notre contribution à l'économie
américaine
nous payons tous les impôts que nous
devons chaque dollar
nous ne respectons pas seulement les
lois week mais aussi l'esprit venoix
cette belle profession de foi n'a pas
vraiment convaincu carl levin le
sénateur démocrate qui présidait la
commission
vous avez transférer une partie des
bénéfices de votre poule aux oeufs d'or
en irlande
vous l'avez transférés dans des filiales
qui ne payent pas de taxe là bas car en
fait elles n'existent même pas en termes
de législation fiscale
ces tactiques d'évasion fiscale que nous
mettons ici en lumière ont beaucoup de
mal elle décharge le poids de ce que
doit apple sur le dos des contribuables
surtout les classes moyennes les petites
entreprises et enfin ce manque-à-gagner
agrafes notre énorme déficit budgétaire
à ce jour aucune action légale n'a été
engagée par l'état les géants du net se
désolidarise de plus en plus de noix
qu'il considère obsolète
[Musique]
sur le siège de facebook ce n'est pas le
drapeau américain qui flotte mais celui
des pirates
tout un symbole les bandits des mers ne
connaissait pas de frontières
les géants du net non plus pour mark
zuckerberg les frontières des états sont
devenus des entraves au business des
entraves qu'il faut abolir
pour cela il a créé un groupe de
pression
financé par tout le gratin des nouvelles
technologies bill gates
monsieur microsoft marissa meyer madame
yahoo ou red hoffman le patron de
linkedin
ce groupe de pression s'appelle
forwarders il est animé par claude
choules tu un ancien de l'équipe obama
leur credo - frontières et plus
d'immigration mais une immigration
choisie
notre pays se portera mieux si on peut
faire venir plus d'ingénieurs qualifiés
de partout dans le monde
ce que l'on entend dans les discussions
et ce qui est confirmé étude après étude
c'est que c'est dur de trouver des
ingénieurs américains qualifiés ici pas
assez d'ingénieurs américains
ce n'est pas ce que dit une étude très
sérieuse publiée par le think tank pays
cette étude affirme que la moitié
seulement des ingénieurs américains
qualifiés travail vous pouvez la voir
ici
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je ne
m'attendais pas à ça non je ne vois pas
ça comme ça il y a sûrement des choses
nous ce qu'on veut c'est s'assurer que
les ingénieurs qui viennent de
l'étranger soit utilisée d'une bonne
manière
si les géants du net tiennent tant à
faire venir des ingénieurs de l'étranger
c'est surtout pour des raisons
économiques
les indiens et les chinois seraient
payés 20 % moins cher toujours selon
l'étude du think tank
le lobby forwarders se développe à toute
vitesse
après dix-huit mois d'existence il ouvre
son 8ème bureau dans le pays
bienvenue à tous pour le lancement du
bureau de for orders à san francisco je
suis très contente
dans cette fête d'inauguration des
dizaines de jeunes volontaires venus des
startups du coin
leur ambition reprogrammé le système on
ne peut pas se satisfaire de cette
médiocrité de ce système obsolète qu'on
nous propose c'est pour ça que
forwarders veut organiser la communauté
des nouvelles technologies car nous
pensons que s'il existe un groupe
capable de construire un système nouveau
et bien c'est nous un groupe de rêveurs
et de bâtisseurs moins de frontières
moins d'impôts le rêve est de remplacer
les citoyens par des followers
ce nouveau monde un homme incarne mieux
que quiconque team drapper un
investisseur qui est devenu milliardaire
grâce à skype et autres mails à longueur
de colloques
il dénonce le rôle de l'état aujourd'hui
le gouvernement dit tu travailles pour
moi donc nous sommes passés d'un pays
très libre à un pays qui évolue de plus
en plus vers l'esclave âge quand un
gouvernement te force à travailler pour
lui
eh bien tu deviens son esclave pour
échapper à cet esclavage tine rapport à
une solution radicale
il prône la sécession de la silicon
valley avantage toute la richesse
générée par les géants du net ne
bénéficierait plus qu'aux deux millions
d'habitants de la région cendres osé ce
jour là tim drapper participe à un salon
de nouvelles technologies nous tentons
une première approche
non je ne peux pas vous parler je dois
monter sur scène tim @ drapper point vie
si si vous avez besoin de mon email sur
scène jared leto acteurs oscarisés
investisseurs importants dans les
nouvelles technologies
je pense que les nouvelles technologies
prennent une grande part dans nos vies
et rendent un grand service au monde je
ne sais pas si c'est parce que j'ai
vendu de la drogue quand j'étais ado
mais tout ça m'intéresse car je suis un
entrepreneur mais aujourd'hui l'acteur
oscarisé n'est qu'un chauffeur de salle
la véritable star c'est tim drapper je
ne crois pas que j'ai besoin de
présenter cet homme assis à ma gauche
comme d'habitude sur scène tine rappeur
s'en prend à son ennemi numéro un de
l'êta si vous allez dans n'importe quel
bureau du gouvernement il suffit de
regarder les ordinateurs et les looks
vous allez voir ils vivent tous dans les
années 90 on ne doit pas laisser ça
arrive et ce monopole a besoin d'être
remplacés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fin du show j'attrape team drapper à sa
sortie de scène
est ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui que
la silicon valley et besoin de l'état je
pense que le gouvernement est important
pour toute société
mais un gouvernement en concurrence avec
d'autres serait beaucoup plus efficace
qu'un gouvernement feignants qui se
repose sur son monopole et si la silicon
valley devient indépendante
est-ce que vous allez payer des impôts
vous voulez savoir comment l'argent
serait répartie et bien les dirigeants
que nous choisirons cours ont enfin
décidé où ira notre argent et en dirons
nous avons gagné cette quantité d'argent
combien nous voulons payer en impôts je
ne comprends pas le sens de votre
question vous pensez d'une manière
obsolètes ou l'argent doit aller au
gouvernement français qui décide qui va
en bénéficier
ça crée une culture du besoin au lieu
d'une culture d'opportunités
c'est une culture de feignants au lieu
de gens agressifs et dynamique
allez les français battez vous
la sécession c'est bien mais la fin des
pays ce serait encore mieux
bonjour c'est l'idée de patrie friedman
petit fils de prix nobel d'économie et
programmateur star chez google
aujourd'hui les gens sont plus heureux
avec leur voiture ou leur smartphone
qu'avec leur gouvernement donc notre
premier point commun c'est qu'on trouve
tout ce que le gouvernement actuel ne
fonctionne pas par chance avec
l'explosion d'internet et l'importance
énorme des technologies nous sommes
plutôt riche
du coup on peut travailler en ligne
depuis une ville flottante
donc tout cela est parfait les villes
flottantes c'est la grande idée de
patrie friedman il veut les installer au
large des etats-unis dans les eaux
internationales
là où elles n'auront plus d'impôts à
payer et pourront inventer leur propre
loi
ce meilleur des mondes pourrait sortir
de l'eau au printemps prochain et
accueillir environ 300 habitants le
milliardaire peter thiel cofondateur de
paypal fait partie du projet avec leur
île les oligarques du net s'imagine même
redistribuer les cartes de la
géopolitique mondiale aux villes
flottantes sont des solutions
scientifiques aux problèmes politiques
et de nature humaine puisque chaque
recoin de la terre appartient à
quelqu'un
pourquoi ne pas s'installer dans l'océan
et créer un nouveau pays
de plus l' océan a quelque chose de
particulier dans sa nature physique
il bouge donc si la corée du nord et la
corée du sud
ou alors israël et la palestine étaient
des pays flottant il pourrait par
exemple bouger chacun de mille
kilomètres et éviter les guerres ses
idées ne sont plus seulement des utopies
de geek
grâce à leur fortune les milliardaires
du net ont aujourd'hui les moyens de
réaliser leurs ambitions
et un homme politique défend leurs idées
rand paul bonsoir y met ce sénateur
républicain a été désigné homme le plus
intéressant aux politiques par le très
sérieux times magazine
le gouvernement n'est pas la solution à
notre problème le gouvernement c'est le
problème
rand paul est le chef de file des
libertariens ce courant qui prône
l'abolition de l'état
il n'a jamais été aussi puissant aux
états unis espère jouer les trouble fête
aux prochaines élections présidentielles
au terme de mon enquête je vois mon
ordinateur un peu différemment un outil
bien pratique qui a envahi ma vie mais
pas seulement
la révolution entamée par les géants du
net il ya 20 ans n'en est sans doute
qu'à son début
et nul ne sait vers quel nouveau monde
et nous conduira
[Musique]